a lot of politicians skate around the
truth but it's never been this bad
in a tweet president trump warned that a
migrant caravan headed to the united
states
included criminals and middle easterners
did he have evidence for this
press secretary sarah sanders said he
absolutely did
vice president mike pence also chimed in
so it's
it is inconceivable that there would not
be
individuals from the middle east
inconceivable of course trump finally
admitted that
there's no proof of anything there's no
proof of anything
but they could very well be huh so how
did major news networks cover trump's
unfounded claims on the migrant caravan
at cnn and msnbc reporters were putting
faces to the story of the caravan
i don't think we are abusing the kids
she says we can't leave them at home
they have to eat i want them to study
have a good future i do this for my kids
they also spent a decent amount of time
clarifying that there wasn't any proof
of what trump was saying
let's check in at fox news this is an
invasion
this is an act of attacking the united
states sovereignty
i did see visibly ms-13 members within
the group
and they're coming in with diseases such
as smallpox and leprosy and tb that are
going to affect our people in the united
states
fox news anchors and hosts continued to
frame the caravan
as an invasion despite the fact that the
alleged pittsburgh synagogue shooter
posted this moments before the shooting
at one point they sent reporter griff
jenkins down to the border
to literally wait in a bush and ambush a
family trying to cross
when he asked why they were doing this
the mother of the family said
the situation of honduras you could not
have
work in there because the criminals
always
will get your money so why did trump
cause all this commotion about the
caravan
well the midterm elections were right
around the corner the democrat party
is openly inviting millions of illegal
aliens to break
our laws violate our borders and
overwhelm
our nation leading up to the midterms
fox and friends mentioned the caravan 19
times on friday
ten times on monday and nine times on
tuesday
the day after the midterms one mention
and that was in passing
republicans are great at taking
advantage of the news
and trump has control of what the news
covers this creates a dilemma for
journalists
should newsrooms ignore issues like the
caravan allowing trump to have his
claims going checked or should they
cover the issue with as much intensity
giving life to its relevance for days on
end
it's important to refute lies that are
coming from the administration
but a more calculated approach is
necessary keep in mind that this isn't
the first caravan this year there was
one in april too
but thanks to trump public interest
about caravans
skyrocketed just before the midterms
news organizations should do their due
diligence in covering important stories
but they must be wary about playing into
the president's hands
cnn and msnbc might have covered the
caravan too much
but they avoided being pawns by not
framing the caravan
as a threat it can't be the case that
news is used to frighten americans
and we cannot let trump's fear mongering
get to our heads